T
DOWNING STREET BE  T  AEL0
WE ARE BTONYLAFROM THOSE OLD
>>
WONDERING ABOUT ISD RAONONAL,
, ANGRUR
AN
VE
T WE N IPETEERN FACE OSSIA.
E FOUNE RM
RUSSIAOO DECEDOLIDATPON
AUTOCRATIC WAY AND BECALIST.
SOHE
LIKECOLDLCUTULSAL
WIMSTHE ANXIETATNK THS NO DACRRU
THISMISCALCULATIONTHCKF THCULATE
UK KNOW UKRAINE,  KNOWSS THERF
BTOIAWAY. THERYN AWAR THERIENTD
TALIN THOSMES
>> THAT'S RIGHT. O TALKING CA BF
HISTORY OFAD
NATO?
LIRULTR  MYTH THAT WERO PUSH
D HEDOESN'T HAAY OUT.?S THAT HIR
THATAID  PORRIESARYOU OF THE VI
A FACE-SAVING
WAOUT?
HI G TND
SHIP H BEE
THEY WOUAVP.MPRESSIVE.I N PRESIN
B
TN
O T HOLE AND
K KREAY,RAINIA WDOL LITER THAN G
TOOMOMENT, IFHE A
Y OF AD UTA LOE ISY ANRAHAT PUTG
THINKHERE ARE LAR
ISND THETURE OCH
JUST AS THEM THEY  TUM MENT MME
GE GAME  THER INHEOF S, WHICH I
AGAIN, OF TIALCULAS  DON'T MAGIK
E G AT
A NEIS IS D INIS
SANCTIONS, THE ACTBL O
THINK THEY WILK IN REMAINSR.N WA
UN REMAIE NGES LESSON NOW.
IT WILCHLL D
AND GAS.AY TAKE SOME TIMCASEJ T
BUT THAT WILHAIT'S ABSOLUTELY IT
NEANESF HAVING A NFLICT BETWEEN
RUSSIAN ENERGYEFORE I LET YO, TG
STN IRELAN
A PARTY  POWERT IN  OLD
IRD ND UNITED?
IT'CKN S N Y THAT
BUE  THINGATLE LR PLAY.
THKE GPUBETWEEN THE UK AND E
SOLVED.
O ANUT OF
TO20
DOESN'T REALLY WTO KEEP TOD UNSC
HOW YOU ORGANIZE BETWEEN
N HE'S GOING TO VEL IT AND EEAHE
I BTHE SY SY THE UK
SOMETHING LIY EALING WITRO TORSW
HAVE THIS MOME.MOMENT YOU TAKE
OF TEN
THE NORTH OFLAND AND S  H BORDEE
.S ALWAYSOINGPROBLED US LOOK,